oh no he's dying he has 24 beats I'm not
gonna fail at this awful game hey guys
welcome to another episode of the
Wednesday checkup
I'm holding a scalpel and I have my
scrubs on we're gonna be playing another
surgery game this time it's gonna be
amateur surgeon you guys requested it
also I have to let you know before we
start you have to come to the channel
this Sunday at 11 o'clock am Eastern
Standard Time because my Kido video goes
live you asked me to try Kido I did it
for a full month I vlog I sat down I
talked about it all my results
everything and for now I guess let's get
started with amateur surgeon are we live
don't swim games I guess it's a riot of
kids are watching I actually hit play oh
my god I literally have to use a pizza
cutter okay
please select the tongs grab a piece of
bone and what I'm gonna put his ribs
together I don't understand Oh got one
in there's something satisfying about
fixing ribs there's something so
delicious about this suture him up Oh
staples we staple in this bad boy
oh we're gonna cauterize this glass
extraction ooh
physics painful all right we gotta get
the tongs to get the glass out Oh
didn't mean to no oh use the tongs to
grab the piece of slowly and clearly
slowly I told you guys that you
shouldn't ever take out glass out of
your body because you can truly hurt
yourself by hard hurting your arteries
oh no wrong area now we gotta burn him
by the way this is not how we do it what
is this
are we vacuuming oh no he's dying he has
24 beats I'm not gonna fail at this
awful game see if I can do it in time oh
come on give me an extra second Doug it
seems to be
my computer just went into power-save
mode how why I'm gonna replay this bad
boy especially now that I know what I'm
doing let's do this we're gonna fix
these pieces of glass and I told you
before don't take out any object that
gets inserted inside of you because oh
come on you can truly hurt yourself if
there's any kind of cut artery behind
that by the way we don't close most
wounds with staples this is super
inaccurate we close most wounds with
sutures
if they're on the scalp or on an area we
need to close fast that we use staples
let's burn some stuff pizza cutter hot
well all you need to be accurate whoa
we're inside these lungs do not look
accurate I love it we're throwing
staples on his lungs we do not leave
staples inside humans bodies and the
best part about it is we don't burn real
lungs but for some reason it feels good
to do he needs pink oh I got to do this
quickly Here I am talking but you got to
actually save a life come on come on
Mikey all of you the staples in here
let's get the staples the burning and
then the pain away I just say excuse me
planned I'm trying to save a life here
what are you doing bro bro back up back
up ro I thought so we just saved a life
what's that
how about you just back up a little bit
huh my god some plants they don't even
know what they're doing this guy's not
even real and he's just trying to be
here with me all right it's 11 p.m. and
I'm losing my mind I'm sorry let's work
on Cletus the fetus wow that porcupine
has a hillbilly spectrum okay this is
getting crazy oh oh oh he's got a he's
got a serious little condition let's
pull these thingies out he's bleeding
rapidly but we're gonna patch him up
we're gonna fix him with these staples
even though it's completely inaccurate
you know we used a coterie tool actually
it's called an electric artery tool in
the operating room but we only use it to
stop bleeds for example if a patient we
hit a little artery and it's sprinkling
blood we can use the Carter tool to help
it stop bleeding
instead of using a clamp and again I'm
burning his kidney oh sorry buddy oh we
got to go multiple incisions look at
this but now we have to use the tongs
not the thongs to get these thorns out
of his liver which totally makes sense
and now we gotta burn him and his liver
I don't know why I'm burning his liver
it makes no sense medically kind of
close them up and we're gonna be good to
go
burn pain away why you got to go again
just do it has too much going on with
them I don't think I'm gonna be able to
save them I don't think there's too many
wounds why you gotta really be quick at
this game this is this game is no joke I
was here trying to have a good time but
this game is serious
[Music]
come on Cletus penis come on green I
don't like losing this much no come on
don't don't do that
don't give me that you could tell I'm
not a real gamer because I can't talk
and play this game I clearly need to
concentrate just to rub the goo on this
guy's breasts dan stop laughing it's all
good I'm getting the pizza cutters I'm
cutting into his left lower quadrant
here to get to his kidneys which would
be actually in his back but it's okay
I'm getting the little prods out of his
kidneys I don't know how my man got
prods in this kidneys this isn't a
strategy game by the way this is just
like pure how fast I can click my mouse
as a proud family medicine doc I have to
save Cletus roadkill Oh if you make a
mistake he bleeds faster you guys are
probably watching this and you're like
what is this guy doing and how is this
medically educational it's not you sure
yeah you should be under sedation
cleanness yeah we saved Cletus you know
before you go I think you should click
right here cuz I think this is a video
you're really gonna like as always stay
happy and healthy but you
[Music]